hey guys I just got back from PAX Prime
and I got a lot of stuff that I want to
talk about and a lot of stuff to cover
and not a lot of time to do it first off
thank you everyone who said hi to me at
the convention and thank you everyone
who came to the panel my very first
panel which was totally awesome by the
way
and thank you Wade for joining me on
that panel and thank you all the
youtubers who I met while I was there
and thank you to the developers who took
the time to talk to me and I'm honestly
surprised because a lot of you had no
idea who I was but honestly some of them
and still did especially in the indie
mega booth
I just thank you everyone who took the
time to say hi to me and I owe a lot of
stuff to cover first of all many fans
came up to me especially during the
signing and the meetup that we had in
the middle of the Seattle there and I
just wanted to show some of it off first
of all Oh first of all uh-huh
as I was walking down the street on the
way to the Meetup this adorable little
kid I think his name was Luke ran
straight up to me like waving his arms
running down the street it was the most
adorable thing I've ever seen I have
some pictures of it and he gave me this
which it may not seem like much it's a
bag of gummy worms and gummy sharks but
he gave it to me and I cannot bring
myself to eat this because it's just the
cutest thing I could ever get from
anyone and I'm sorry other fans out
there this is awesome I don't even know
if these are gonna spoil sometime in the
future but I love this present so much
thank you so much for giving it to me
Luke and thank you for coming up and
saying hi to me and I'm sorry because
some of my videos are definitely not for
kids but I'm glad that you enjoy the
videos that I do make so sincerely thank
you so much and uh the next one is
actually not from packs a weight
actually came over and gave this to me
he got it a family did a meet-up in Ohio
so thank you it's even opposable arms
and stuff like that and it's from our
drunk minecraft series in which I
promise is coming back we have recorded
it I have not had time to edit with all
the things that I've been preparing but
just thank you so much whoever made this
I don't know your name but seriously
thank you so much
also just to go through this quickly we
got a tiny box Tim here and the tiny box
Tina here I don't know if that the
couple link here is canon but it is here
and this one even talks
indeed watch out for the boat stabber
and we have this awesome statue of it's
um uh okay we have this statue here not
time for that yet anyway we have this
cool statue that someone handmade with
some goodies inside of it that you can
see there thank you so much and finally
oh god it's fall apart and finally we
have uh one of the fans gave this to me
and is anyway it's a little cute chicken
that sings the chicken dance song and
it's only mildly disturbing especially
when it was by my bed you can shut up
now especially one who's by my vag is
staring at me with it's one beady eye
right there watching me as my sleep
nicely but you know what it reminds me
of my good buddy senpai ray actually
finally met up with me and he gave me
this awesome roosterteeth spirit for
totally free and stole it from someone
else he was about to buy it probably I
don't know I told him I didn't need one
but seriously thank you so much for
meeting up with me and thinking that I'm
a cool guy those notes were his exact
words he said I was a cool guy which is
totally awesome anyway so ray from
achievement hunters on roosterteeth
thank you so much and he said that he
was gonna do whatever it takes to get me
the roosterteeth Expo next year so you
can look forward to that bomb and take
this off cause it's hot as hell over
here and my hair is is taking a beating
you guys like what I've done with my
hair I need a haircut very badly
we're gonna go email for a little bit
here turn into emo vampire dark a blower
here
that's my dark applier if everyone can
make their own dark apart mine's the emo
vampire no understand me my are
let's go listen to my music and make my
pose ready anyway there's also cool fan
art that someone made for me thank you
so much for this caricature work and
thank you to Jasmine booty for making
this for me it's adorable and we got
another one here that's really cool if
you look at it this way
it says Mark Fischbach I don't know how
well you can read that but it's really
well then but if you turn it upside down
it says markipliergame that is awesome
thank you so much to sum me perez Rivera
thank you seriously thank you everyone
who came up and said hi to me thank you
everyone who came to the Meetup
it was incredible when I turned that
corner and saw how many people were
there
this whole convention has just been an
astonishing experience okey-dokey then
this whole convention has been an
amazing experience because every time I
go out to these places and I'm able to
meet with you guys one on one and I'm
able to just converse with you and hear
your stories I always get so inspired to
continue doing what I've been doing it
and more than that you know I always
feel like I am moving in the right
direction I am using what I have
responsibly and what I have is a giant
community of awesome people who are
willing to share with each other and
point each other towards charitable
efforts and actually support the things
that I believe in which is more than I
could ever ask for and seeing it when I
was in that panel and hearing the
stories especially the guy named Colin
who said that his life was not going in
the right direction and he's been
through a lot of hardship and then you
know my videos were able to help them
out it's it really solidifies why I do
this and it's so cool to see that people
accept because I have fun with what I do
and if you see the panel I'm totally
silly and ridiculous most of the time
because I am having the time of my life
just being there with you guys and
enjoying life in a general and playing
video games and all this cool stuff and
at the same time we can be serious
enough to recognize recognize recognize
that what we do here is important
you know what you guys do is important
you guys in general are important and we
can sit down and understand that
everything here is so important and so
necessary what we do here is absolutely
100% necessary and just thank you guys
so much for everything that you've done
for me and I look so forward to meeting
you guys in another convention because I
can't get enough of it yeah especially
the Meetup I am sorry to anyone who got
misled because I said that you didn't
need a badge to get in the panel or the
signing session I stayed in that square
from 5:00 until a little after 9:00 I
believe so it wasn't terribly long that
I was there but once again I'm just very
sorry to everyone that I wasted the time
of and I was sitting in a sea of just
probably like 200 people and I was just
amazed that so many people turned up and
I was so grateful that everyone was
patient and I tried to prioritize kids
first and people that'd go people like
parking spots and whatnot the day to get
out of just thank you for everyone for
being understanding and giving me a
chance to try to meet you all one on one
because I want to give everyone the time
that they deserve and that as a wasp Oh
okay wasp crisis over but anyway just
thank you guys so much for believing in
what I do and I probably got my
attention cuz I was getting rambley
again but I really do look forward to
the next convention that I get to go to
I hope I have another panel I hope that
Wade or Bob can be there when I'm there
because I would hate to do that alone
because running around with no one up at
the bench or whatever you want to call
it up there would organize the thing not
that it was organized anyway but you
know what I mean it was still a lot of
fun and I'm just SuperDuper grateful
that you guys are there for me and gosh
you guys are awesome that's all I gotta
say you guys are awesome every single
person I met was awesome and I wish I
could remember all of your names I wish
I could call you up by name it and just
give shoutouts to all of you but just
thank you all in general oh and before I
forget there was one more thing I wanted
to talk about if you like Wharf stashing
you-know-who Wharf stashes there was
another video involving him that a lot a
lot of people know about yet he is right
over here on Sena goes channel we got to
do another sketch comedy with him so I
just wanted to say thank you guys for
doing all the work on that I did some
shooting obviously and then I acted in
it but they did most of the editing and
post-production work I turned out
fantastically you guys can see it right
now I highly recommend it it's pretty
funny and pretty awesome if I do say so
myself so that's about it so sincerely
from me to you guys thank you for being
here for me I will let you know the
second I have another convention on the
Verizon our charity livestream will
probably be the last weekend of this
month which is either the 26 or the 27th
whatever the Saturday is of this month
at the end that's when the new charity
livestream will be probably weighed will
be there Bob probably won't because he's
in law school and will be very busy but
I look forward so much to the future
because just I'm so excited for what's
coming so thank you guys so much for
watching and as always is that the wasp
I will see you that was a wasp in the
next video
bah bah hee I'm gonna die